[Music]
well everyone thanks for joining us you
know today we're going to talk about how
Pandora moved and migrated its
on-premises bi and analytics GCP I'm
joined by Brett who's the VP of platform
services at Pandora media and I myself
am late why I'm part of the professional
services organization at Google cloud
helping some of our largest customers
move and migrate their loop to GCP we
are going to use be using a Dory today
it's accessible through your next app we
encourage everyone who has questions now
or throughout the talk to just go into
the app jot them down if you have time
to look at the existing questions and
possibly upload them at the end of the
talk we're gonna be taking questions
from the audience at the microphones and
the dory alternating thank you
and lastly just a little bit about the
agenda Brett's going to give it an
instruction to Pandora and talk about
the Big Data evolution we're gonna talk
about why pandora chose to move to the
cloud in GCP specifically some of the
evaluation and results that took place
before their commitment and we're gonna
go into some of the technical details
around the solution RER Kotecha
before kind of finalizing with you know
the rest of the roadmap for the year and
you know what we hope to see Pandora
present at next twenty twenty right cool
thanks Blake all right so who we are
Pandora we had a show of hands how many
of you have used the Pandora app before
all right it's great showing thank you
very much for listening another show of
hands how many of you have used our
on-demand service our premium okay
pretty good now how many of you know
that you can search and play with our
free ad-supported version
have you tried out that feature yet even
smaller group okay well go check it out
it's a really exciting feature we
launched a few months ago we're really
excited about it
but one of the things we do at Pandora
that's really at sort of the core of of
Pandora is our personalization so the
idea with Pandora is that you can have a
Leanback experience you give us some
cues and we program a continuous stream
of content for you whether it's music or
non music content like podcasts or
comedy so you know at the heart of this
personalization is our analytics system
it's really the workhorse behind it so
we have we have a lot of data
sixty-eight million users in the u.s.
we've got those users have created over
13 billion stations over the life of
Pandora and 90 billion pieces of
feedback thumbs up or thumbs down
telling us what they like or don't like
and we use all that data for this
personalization so I'll tell you a
little bit about the history of Big Data
at Pandora I've actually been at Pandora
11 years and was really involved since
the beginning with analytics at Pandora
so we launched behind or in 2005 in
2008-2009 mobile really exploded and the
usage of Pandora really took off so
originally we had a single Postgres
database we're stuffing all of our
analytics data into it and it didn't
scale very well as you can imagine so
2010 we started experimenting with
Hadoop on Prem and we built out our
first to dupe cluster moved all of our
analytics over to Hadoop started with a
very modest cluster ten servers Apache
point one seven and hive point five and
we've grown on Prem quite a bit so every
year we've had growth we've we've added
more engineers more analysts more
scientists all working on a single
cluster we have one production cluster
that runs everything on Pandora
and we've also added a lot of
personalization features so thumbprint
radio if any of you use that
personalized soundtracks autoplay all
these personalized features for our
listeners
we've also added features for our
advertisers as well really cool campaign
reporting tools some some really
advanced forecasting so they can make
sure they have the right campaign and
some cool segmenting and targeting as
well so with all those features with all
that growth we grew the cluster so today
we are up to 2,700 data nodes 7
petabytes of data and and quite a few
resources on this thing so 270 terabytes
of RAM 76,000 V course just like 10,000
foot overview of how analytics works at
Pandora you know we have the data
ingestion side of things we leveraged
Kafka really heavily heavily almost all
of our kind of real-time event data that
happens as you trigger actions in the
app comes through Kafka now we use scoop
and some homegrown tools to load data
from our relational databases into
Hadoop so load of load all that stuff
into HDFS leverage hive and spark very
heavily for all our ETL and batch
workloads presto and hive are the
primary tools that our scientists
developers analysts use as they're
looking for insights we also have a
couple BI tools we rely on heavily
Zeppelin and tableau for insights and
then you know a large percentage of what
our workload is on the cluster are
really jobs that our development team
our science team has built doing that
personalization and pushing those
pushing that personalization that we do
typically in a batch process into
production stores that we can run our
real-time services off of and make these
decisions in real time
so Postgres and Redis reticent
particular we rely on really heavily so
disaster recovery with our current
on-prem architecture we have our main
cola which is in San Jose we do have a
backup I would call it more of a
business continuity backup not true
disaster recovery we have a much smaller
cluster very data dense that's located
outside of DC we have a 40 gig buy link
that we copy data to pretty much all the
time to keep that at least a copy of our
data up to date but the big drawback
with this is if we did mean to failover
and rely on our backup datacenter it
would take us some time to scale that
out to really take on the production
workload it's just not feasible to run
two clusters the same size and just be
sitting idle all the time so why cloud
you know we've been on prim for a long
time why would we kind of pick up and
move to the cloud and that was a big
question for us so you know a lot of
different reasons bursty workloads is a
really interesting one let me just put a
pin in that for a minute there's a cool
slide I want to show you next that gets
into that a little bit but another
another Avenue of flexibility is
hardware choices so we have different
workloads some of them spark presto very
memory intensive they can do a lot with
a memory if you give it to them and you
know all of our jobs are different we
have one single cluster and we run a lot
of different types of workloads so being
able to switch to a model where we've
separated storage and compute and we can
spin up purpose-driven clusters with
different profiles for different
workloads yeah is really appealing to us
all so multi-regional I mentioned I
mentioned the Dr situation for us being
able to have a true disaster recovery
is pretty cool reduce maintenance you
know as the cluster has grown the last
two or three years we spent more and
more of our time operationally just
keeping the cluster running for all of
our users we've got about 150 users on
the cluster across the company and
managing the the resources between them
and and you know we've hit quite a few
bugs just because of our scale things
like storage tiering and also
understanding cost at a more granular
level has been really cool so this is
another one on flexibility here this is
a chart of our Hadoop utilization over a
month and if you look at this chart you
say ok well things things are looking
pretty good you're you're under 40
percent 35 percent across the board as a
mean but because we run one cluster we
have a lot of different users on it
we're actually resource constrained a
lot of the time you know people come in
in the morning they want to execute
their queries they want to learn about
what happened the previous day and so we
have bottleneck and backups so even
though this looks good is really not
that efficient because when people want
to use the cluster they can't always get
instant access to it and so we looked
around we looked at the different cloud
providers and something that really
meshed well with Pandora and what we're
trying to achieve at Pandora it was a
good fit for GCP and the Google team and
I think the things that stood out for us
is really the distributed computing
expertise Google has a a very rich
history with distributed computing you
know Hadoop is based on the original
Google file system and and MapReduce
papers more recently announcing the the
really cool innovations with spanner and
the way that kind of novel way that they
handle transactions distributed
transactions across the
that's pretty exciting too one other
thing while this this talk and in our
focus so far has been on analytics one
of the things that's been a challenge
for us at pandora is real-time
distributed computing we built a
sharding layer on top of Postgres way
back in 2011 because there weren't a lot
of choices for helping us scale out for
real-time datastore so right now we're
focused on analytics but we're doing
some investigations with both
multi-regional spanner and BigTable as
as potential data stores for our
real-time services so that was a really
good fit and Google's focus on AI and
machine learning was was a really good
match for us the investment in
tensorflow the ability to run
specialized computing hardware for
graphics the the TP use is pretty
exciting in particular we had a lot of
success about big R with bigquery as
well and I will go into some more
details as we get into the meat of this
so we kicked off an evaluation just to
give you kind of a sense of the timeline
you know we're we're we're good size
organization and this this was this was
a big change for us so it took some time
to get buy-in from business to get
everybody aligned and make sure we're
moving forward in the right direction so
we kicked off some preliminary research
into the various cloud providers at the
end of 2017 in q1 2018 we did a
proof-of-concept spend about three
months building that up and by the end
of that from a technical point of view
we knew what we wanted to do when you
won't want to go GCP we spent a couple
months working with a lot of
stakeholders around the business our
partners in finance building out a
financial model you know something that
was tricky for us is that we had this
big investment on Prem we had a Colo
lease that went out several years we had
a lot of hardware we'd already invested
in and so how do we make the switch to
on Prem it's not art to GCP and the
cloud and it's not something that
happens
overnight so it took some some creative
work there to make the numbers work out
but we got to a point where we feel like
when we finish this migration we're
going to be in a good spot and very
comparable cost wise to where we are
today on prim so the end of 2000 or the
end of last year we started our
migration planning trying to figure out
the priority of how we migrate and move
forward in q1 we migrated some of our
initial data sets and at the end of this
month we're looking to get our first set
of early adopters onto the GCP platform
which is pretty exciting still a long
way to go but making great progress so
with our POC what we did was took one of
our largest data sets so this data set
is it's called Mads master advertising
delivery data set it's really all of the
ad impressions that for all the ads
served on Pandora it's a very large data
set one of our largest about 15 billion
records in this data set every month we
keep a couple years actually two or
three years of this data around for for
long running campaigns and to do history
so move this process up onto GCP
leveraging data proc it's really a spark
job that does combines a lot of
different data sources into one data set
normalizes that data and puts a lot of
abstracts away a lot of the business
logic that downstream consumers of this
data so they don't really need to know
about that so this all went really well
we found increased query performance
with with bigquery huh gives you some
some numbers in a minute the batch
workload was also optimized about 35%
fewer resources to do the same amount of
work and then this consolidation I we
were able to move all of these sources
into a singular table
so this is my favorite slide this was
actually what we did was we took the
gnarliest queries that we ran on prim on
this data set and we ran them against
bigquery ran them against our presto
instance on Prem against our hive on
Prem and I think not only the the quick
results here but the consistency across
all under 30 seconds here very reliable
so this was really really exciting for
us so as we talked about the migration
you know this is a long process we have
a lot of jobs running on the cluster a
lot of users on the cluster we think
this is about an 18-month effort and
we're part of the way in you know
originally we did a pilot we moved a
couple data sets up different types got
some experience did a lot of the
infrastructure work cloud is new for us
I'll talk about that in a minute but you
know it's a different animal and there
was a lot of learning there now we're
deep into the core datasets migrating
the data sets that are most heavily used
by the company up there we'll do that
and then there's going to be some long
tail and and also an opportunity we've
built some tools that tell us really
what's being used on Prem how often it's
being used and so to do that we're gonna
we've been able to prioritize the
workloads that we're moving over and I
think would do some spring cleaning as
well so areas of focus you know I
mentioned we spent a lot of time on on
the infrastructure we wanted to get
right and it was a it was a new muscle
for us so we leveraged terraform very
heavily we want everything to be really
repeatable between our our operations
team and our tech ops team they built
essentially a project creation tool so
someone that wants to go and use the GCP
platform
Pandora now goes to a portal creates
gives us some information gives us some
contact and relevant information about
what this project is going to be used
for and that kicks off some terraform
that goes and creates the project gives
them the right set of permissions and
does thing in a standard and
reproducible way so that was really cool
you know VP sees where another thing
took us a while to get right we worked a
lot with the the Google PSO group and
some of the product teams learned a lot
there but also automated that as well so
the VP C's get attached to the these
projects as they get created also
important thing for us was budgeting so
being able to map these projects to
different budgets and understand what
that use case was going to be because
even now just our short time on GCP you
know I think we're it I don't know
nearing 100 projects or so and then of
course the users are going to be an
important track you know it's it's a
switch we use hive we use presto on-prem
bigquery is still sequel but there's
some nuance there there's some UDF's
that will be transforming and it's going
to be a learning process we think we're
going to do this in a few different
tracks we'll have some training for
different types of users we've got the
administrators that have have been kind
of trained up already different tracks
for a developer scientists and analysts
to learn about the platform so this is
really cool you know very early on we
figured out that you know we've we
actually have a lot of cruft on our
system we've been around for a long time
we want to make sure we're spending our
time moving the things that are most
important so shout out to one of our
engineers who's in the audience here
Kate schemata she went and created what
we call the lineage tool so scraped all
the logs from our on-prem cluster
I think timeline server logs route as
job
history for MapReduce some some logs for
presto and from airflow kind of pulled
all that data together figured out the
relationships parse the actual queries
that are being run and figured out
things like what are the top queried
tables dependencies between data data
sets what are like two commonly paired
tables that people join on together when
they're when they're running queries and
then what are the least queried tables
what are things that they just aren't
really being used and and those are
prime candidates to be to be axed and do
a little cleanup so as we get into
migration we took the data from the
lineage tool broke it up into sort of
functional areas of work assign leaders
to the different areas of work and we're
actually also using the same tool to
sort of check off datasets and jobs as
they get migrated and move over to GCP
all right I'm gonna hand it over to
Blake and he's going to go into a little
more deep into the technical details
thanks Brett
[Applause]
so I just first want to call out the the
team in the timeline so first off Google
PSO engage with Pandora in around
November of last year with along with a
wonderful partner some of the those
members are in the I stay so nude Essex
so this was really a combined effort
between Pandora's excellent engineering
organization nude ESSEC and Google PSO
and we're gonna tell you a little bit
about what the architecture looks like
in GCP so one of the first things we did
is kind of target you know pandora has a
large monolithic cluster on-premises and
Brett did a really good job of showing
like some of the inefficiencies and some
of the bursty workloads and some of the
drivers that that pushed them to the
cloud and so they were also facing
cutting some operational burden so they
they really chose GCP data proc which is
GCPs
completely managed Hadoop platform and
we really run data proc and two
different ways so on the left hand side
we see that we spend AB data product job
data product clusters and around 90
seconds or so that are scoped to a
particular job so this is ideal for you
know batch or ETL processes that get run
on a daily basis if not more frequently
and so what we see here is that you know
we're using Apache air flow in the form
of GCP composer and manage versions of
at Apache air flow to basically identify
how much data needs to be processed spin
up a right side stator podcaster do the
ETL or batch process and then persist
the result back to Google Cloud storage
or push it into bigquery on the right
hand side there are some use cases that
Pandora undertakes like the use of hive
or presto for interactive query to
support 150 or so users throughout the
day and these these are served best by
long living or moderately living data
proc clusters these clusters can
actually be spent up in an optimized
fashion per workload for example hive
may need a more balance between computer
and memory while presto would have more
memory intensive machines it also allows
us to it also last Pandora the Pandora
team to spin up new clusters test out
new versions of software via new data
product images to see if they can't
upgrade to a new version of hive or
SPARC kicks
on the edges of some of these things are
some operational tools that are used on
a daily basis so these include things
like Google stackdriver
which has direct integration with GCP
data proc to pull out a lot of yarn
metrics amongst other things as well as
like Google Cloud logging for I am and
other metrics and then lastly kind of on
the edge nodes you know clients can use
edge nodes either in the cloud to spin
up Jupiter or Zeppelin notebooks or they
can also access across the their
interconnect from their own premises
systems so now I'm going to kind of walk
through you know kind of all the pillars
of a successful like data platform on
GCP and kind of wood are some of the
things that you know pandora some key
decisions that kind of had to make and
and kind of what steps that they had to
take so the first look thing we're gonna
talk about is data ingestion right so
you know pandora has over seven
petabytes of data on there there there
Hadoop cluster on-premises today and
they needed to devise a plan to get that
into GCP so the first thing is
connectivity we typically when we work
with customers we we look to see if you
know it's it's the which pattern is
right for them either moving it across
the wire or using some type of transfer
appliance in this case Pandora when we
started working with them had 210 gig
link that was to GCP and you know over
the course of the project that was
increased to 40 gigabit we also learned
throughout the project that like Brett
mentioned earlier with with his comments
on BBC that network design is key so
working with you know infrastructure
folks in the beginning to make sure that
you have that foundation is very very
important you know next week we had a
now that we had connectivity established
we had to go how are we going to get
data into GCP how we're gonna get into
Google Cloud Storage to realize that
separation of compute and storage so
there's really three different patterns
for doing this and you know for those
that are interested these these slides
will be posted in PDF form and this is
actually a link so there's push versus
pull versus kind of having a proxy
cluster so I'm just gonna focus on push
versus pull the push model is we have a
hoodoo
a Hadoop cluster on premises that you
install a GCS connector jar into and you
point it at Google Cloud storage and
move the data over time the other
scenario is you can spin up a Google
Cloud Data proc cluster in GCP point out
your on-premises cluster and pull the
data there are pluses and minuses to
each approach and you can read more on
the link so pandora decided to do with
the push model user existing cluster to
push data into two GCP one of the more
easier options but to do this they they
kind of ran into an issue there is a
Mitch match between check sums between
Hadoop historically and Google Cloud
Storage and not just Google Cloud
Storage but object stores in the cloud
in general at a high level this has to
do with a mismatch between md5 and CRC
check sums so one of the senior staff
engineers within the Google Cloud Data
proc team developed a patch HDFS 1 3 0 5
6 which is a patched 8 to HDFS so the
Google PSO team knew des akin Pandora
collaborated on this patch and applied
this to Pandora's on-premises cluster
through a dev and then I mean through a
dev test and finally a rollout to their
2,700 node production cluster so this
really allowed them to move the data
from all premises to the cloud have
assurances that the integrity of the
data was preserved so that they can
start deleting data sets from
on-premises and that has just started
next is when dealing with data copy when
moving from on-premises to the cloud you
have to be cognizant of data access and
so what I permanently mean about that is
you know the the cost of ingress and
egress from you know Google cloud and
cloud in general the first is ingress so
you know as we move the set up at 7
petabytes of data from on-premises to
the cloud we don't have to worry about
that charge it is completely free but we
do have to be kind of cognizant of
egress charges and they come in two main
forms one is cross zones in a particular
region and when moving between regions
this is especially important when
dealing with disaster recovery and we're
going to talk a little bit about that
later but lastly do do
Pandora's kind of major investment in
bigquery it really kind of softens a lot
of that right so so
any query egress from bigquery is
completely free so when you're serving
analytical applications or bi tools
either in the cloud or back on premises
any grit egress from that engine history
and the last thing I just want to show
you about the slide is that there's a
great excellent blog post that goes into
the details between the HDFS patch that
is required to ensure data integrity but
between on-premises to do clusters in
the cloud and you can read more by
clicking the blog blog post link next
thing I want to do is talk a little bit
about cloud storage so we're moving data
into cloud storage you know on-premises
in in in and on-premises to do cluster
with HDFS there's not the nuanced
durability availability resiliency in
the storage there there is a concept of
storage tiering
but there isn't quite the same analog
into the cloud so the first things that
we had to deal with were kind of like
storage classes so soap it you know
Pandora worked with the PSO team to kind
of understand you know what was right
for them based on the different data
sets that they had so data sets come in
a few major flavors so data sets
gold.gold master data sets that need to
be highly available at a low weight and
C they need to be backed up and vailable
to any type of dr system there there's
data that's created due to intermediate
processes of Lanna litical jobs that can
be rerun and that data requires less
resiliency but you know high performance
and lastly there's kind of just
intermediate data that analysts use like
throughout the data science process and
that may not need high resiliency their
durability or or performance and so what
you see here is an engineer at pandora
you know iggy really empowered his
organization to understand all these
storage classes via the decision tree
like on the right and then next moving
on is permissions so I a lot of times I
go and I work with customers who are
storing a lot of data in HDFS and it's
kind of amazing to see although this
isn't the case of Pandora that you know
the majority of jobs are accessed and a
majority of files are owned by the
Hadoop user right and so when moving to
the cloud
having to understand you know I am
identity access management service
accounts and principles is key right so
we were able to kind of implement a
project-based inherited security model
with projects being scoped applications
and projects being available for dev
test and production to kind of
encapsulate the security of the actual
application and its data so this kind of
goes without saying but you know
separating the computing the storage
really alleviate a lot of pain you know
customers normally experience as did
Pandora that when HDFS gets above 90% or
so capacity that it can bring the entire
cluster to a grinding halt right so you
know that that is a problem that is
completely alleviated by kind of moving
to you know GCP and GCS right it also
kind of increases transparency so you
know now that you know you have data up
in GCS you can really point you know any
type of analytical engine on it add it
and you know it's very easy and then
lastly you know we talked about where we
are in this process it's very early days
for Pandora but one of the you know some
of the discussions are already ongoing
are around of the object lifecycle which
usually requires custom tooling certain
scenarios that you know are kind of
covered under this include what happens
when a data scientist or an analyst
takes a gold master data set runs a
bunch of analysis on it makes them a lot
of analysis result and it's just sitting
in the in and a GCS bucket now that you
have access to unlimited storage you
know you may you may start seeing a
little bit more truffling around so like
how do you manage that how do you ensure
that the permissions are correct how do
you how do you ensure that like data
sets are known to be either intermediary
or gold so on and so forth and so while
manual processes may work at first it's
it's it's very common to build custom
tooling to automate this so so here's a
real meat of the the data platform today
is you know using Cloud Data proc so
there's a lot of there's a few different
ways of using Cloud Data proc and I've
kind of tried to break them down here
into four different ways so we talked
about ephemeral versus long-living
data pot clusters and so this you know
Pandora basically
settled on the the four following you
know methods we're using the aprox so
the first days you know long-running
data pot clusters that run workloads
like pressed or hive but but are capable
of auto scaling so when users are not
using these clusters they can scale down
save cost etc but whenever people come
in in the morning and start firing
queries that they can take an auto scale
right
the next is long-running spark jobs
workload is like kind of streaming
workloads these kind of take take
advantage of auto scaling but may not
scale back down due to some of the some
of the concerns around kind of
intermediate data right and then the
next is the next two are around
ephemeral clusters so you know ephemeral
clusters or job scope clusters can be
brought up to do ETL they can they can
be created you know in 90 seconds we can
create we can create a cluster that has
500 nodes that will run for a period of
minutes which would cost the same as one
cluster running for a one-note cluster
running for five five hundred minutes
and just really see that immense speed
up in like the cycle time for the
particular job and while these don't
necessarily auto scale today they can be
dynamic at startup so when you're using
Apache air flow or composure to create
these clusters you can identify how much
work is being done and pick the amount
of nodes that should be used to to
perform this this job right and then
lastly is kind of ephemeral clusters so
you know jobs that may need to copy data
from one place for another or perform
some type of operation like analyze
tables in hive may be created you know
ephemerally to spin up and spin back
down and short period of time so there's
a few things on the right that I kind of
want to talk about like over the last
five months that we were able to realize
pretty easily by using like a managed to
do service so the first thing is you
know Pandora was able to upgrade to
Hadoop 2.9
so you saw that they were running HTTP
to 6 4 which was Hadoop to 7 2 and it
had a lower version of hive as well so
you know with very little very little
effort we
were able to adopt a data product image
with Hadoop 2:9 in hive 2/3 and and
realize some performance gains the next
is you know I want to talk a little bit
about you know customization of data
proc so data Prague has base images but
they rarely have every single component
that a you know customer may want to
utilize and that was the case with
Pandora right so we you know did a proc
offers a series of top-level components
that are baked into the image that are
enabled or disabled based on flags and
so what this means is since since the
bits already built into the to the image
you can have a litany of components
available within the 90 second cluster
startup time right and so what this
means is is that you just write in an
initialization action that has
configuration and not necessarily bits
that need to be installed right because
the sum of installing all those bits of
Crona across a cluster even a
particularly large cluster could be very
costly both in you know performance as
well as cost and then lastly we talked a
little bit about auto scaling for data
proc but do want to talk about workflow
templates so we're flow templates are a
recent innovation in data proc that
really allows you to spin up a cluster
run a graph of jobs and then let the
cluster spin back down so this this
really really simplifies the the job
scope to ephemeral cluster model where
you once had to like create a data proc
job submit jobs and then understand when
to shut down your cluster this is now
computed for you and easily called by
scheduling systems like airflow next I
want to talk a little about cloud
composer so Pandora is a very big
investor in Apache and airflow they
primarily run airflow 1.8 on-premises
and have over 90 instances today these
instances span the gamut of devtest and
production they have a extensive set of
plugins that they use to do some really
cool stuff one of them is jump job
dependencies so not only do they they
they have a series plugins that will
manage job dependencies across the
airflow instances but they also manage
dependencies across the legacy
schedulers and now recently they've
added functionality to also make
it sees across the cloud as well which
is GCP composer which is managed airflow
they also have a lot of cool operators
that do things like sense whether data
is in hdfs sense whether or not a
partition and hive is available for you
know down to basically enable jobs to
understand if they can move down their
dependency graph continuing on with the
plugins there's also you know kind of a
CI CD built into the the airflow
instances you know since you know
airflow is so pervasive at Pandora its
it's shouldn't come as a shock that it's
not just engineers that use airflow it's
a lot of analyst and scientists too so
how can you you know enable these people
to like quickly write a dag and sync the
updates to the system so they kind of
have a update dag view plugin that kind
of works across air flow and composer
and GCP last when we started this
project upgrades to composer in GCP or a
little crufty to be honest right so we
there was custom scripting that was
required to upgrade minor major versions
of both composer and it's under fly
under underlying airflow and we're
really happy to report that you know as
of next i believe yesterday you know new
functionality was was introduced in
composer that completely automates both
tools upgrade automatically and then
lastly i just kind of talk through this
this system on the right so you know the
the partner that I kind of called out in
the beginning is talk like really took
the lead and developing a composer dag
factory and so what this is is a
framework that runs in composer that
encapsulate all the jobs that are being
migrated to to GCP from Pandora's
on-premises and so it really just wraps
analytical business logic and a lot of
pre checks sensor checks tasks retries
logging etc validation and then also
accuse other processes for downstream
processing as well and so you know this
tag factory is being used to wrap all
the jobs that are being moved to to GCP
from
on premises if you want to learn a lot
more about this you can catch this great
session that's taking place tomorrow
morning so Dan Barrett a staff software
engineer from head or who's in the
audience here today is going to be
speaking with the composer team about
Pandora's move to GCP and composer you
know that's tomorrow morning at the
Metreon theater 7:00 so next is bigquery
so Pandora has recently been
experimenting with bigquery and is is
settling on a production architecture
for its use and so I'm gonna kind of
step through a couple concerns that
customers typically have to you know
understand when they adopt bigquery okay
so the first is is workload management
so first off before we kind of go into
to bigquery just a few concepts for
those that are unfamiliar in the room so
bigquery has it has a few contracts that
are kind of important understand before
we go into this the first is a slot
which is basically just a contract of a
fixed amount of memory and CPU you have
a slot pool so when you interact with
bigquery you have a series of slots that
you either use on-demand or you have a
fixed reservation of these in this case
pandora has 2,000 slots they can make as
many reservations underneath that slot
pool as they would like for a workload
management right and this this this
overall hierarchy is called the
reservation hierarchy and you see an
example on the bottom right of the
screen
so workload management is really here to
enable SOAs and this will allows you to
really maximize your investment in
bigquery so what I mean by maximize is
that what you see here is to kind of
enable some SL A's we're kind of
breaking apart our slot reservation you
know into batch and online right and
we're giving particular projects and
particular applications a fixed amount
of computing and memory power right but
if some of these reservation I mean if
some of these slots are unused by these
these child projects other projects can
actually burst in and use them right so
if for example the mads project is done
with its daily computation and is not
using its slots is f1 users data
scientists that are that are trying to
use the system's will benefit they can
actually just go over and take those
slots
the next is federated query so bigquery
traditionally works on bigquery storage
it's a highly optimized both file format
and storage layer for bigquery that
really enables like true interactive
query but increasingly bigquery supports
more and more federated query sources so
some of those include Google Cloud
storage cloud sequel and a few others
there's there's wonderful announcements
on that at next 2019 so you can Fed rate
query across a variety of formats so the
format's of Pandora primarily uses Avro
park'
or C you know the majority of those
formats are supported for federated
query and you know bigquery supports
komal or columnar data partition support
so if you have data in RC or pork'
format
apparently o RC bigquery will understand
partitions and actually do predicates
push down and optimize the query even if
it's stored external to bigquery you
know what is federated query kind of
enable storage tiering so it's very
common for customers and in Pandora's
case to store their most hot data their
blast and lamby days and bigquery and
then push older or more historical data
into GCS and then do federated query
across reduce at two data sets when when
historical analysis is required the next
is you know high throughput api and
external analysis engines so you know
we're innovating with Pandora the Google
PSO team is is working to build you know
big great storage handler that allows
you know hive and presto to to register
external tables against bigquery data
sets and this will allow for further
federation of queries so so data that is
historically preserved in GCS for for
multiple years can be actually merged
with the the hot data in bigquery and in
queried with one one a
Kalenjin and then lastly you know
exploration is kind of taking place with
BQ ml so for simple regressions
classifications and increasingly other
ml methods like BQ is kind of making it
you know effortless to to run those
against datasets in big queue so some
some kind of partying anecdotes about
the the what we were able to accomplish
over the last five months include kind
of an approach for you know just speed
disaster recovery so like Brett was
mentioning there's an active cluster in
California and a ADR Colo on the East
Coast and they're kind of following a
similar model in in GCP so their primary
region is US central one with the gr
region being US East one and so there's
a couple of advantages of using the
cloud for 4dr right so you know the you
know the first days is that you're not
you don't have to in an access standby
mode have resources be running in your
dash recovery right and if you needed to
actually replicate your entire
production environment in the cloud
that's that's possible by moving to a
second region but there was really one
really neat thing that Pender was able
to adopt within GCS that is gonna make
this quite quite effortless so you know
GCS has a bunch of storage tiering modes
so for those are unfamiliar there's you
know multi-region GCS storage regional
GCS storage and a special type of multi
region is called dual region what this
does is pin your data between two
regions that are known so that's
especially useful in disaster recovery
scenarios amongst others and so this
NAMM for bucket type within GCS is used
by pandora to to store its most
important data and ensure that it's
replicated from you a central one and
u.s. decent one continuously and allow
them to spin up and continue their
business in the event of a disaster in
your central one and they can do that
via you know CI CD tools and
infrastructure and code that they've
developed like throughout this project
as well
and then lastly kind of ending with a
really
early success story for some of the
other tools in GCP so there's the Panera
Music Genome Project so I encourage
everyone to go to Pandora comm slash
about slash MGP and kind of learn a bit
a little bit about this it's a very
comprehensive analysis of of music over
time and what this is is you know kind
of batch feature extraction and
prediction using tensorflow
and so traditionally at pandora this was
done on a single server using other ml
libraries and it would take a matter of
days in in the example here over six
days right so so analyzing over 10,000
mp3s
you know extracting features for
analysis was just done you know very
very slowly and they were able to
quickly port that over to data flow
after this data was loaded into GCS and
you know bring up like 800 cores and
complete this the same effort in less
than four hours and that's just kind of
the start of what they're doing with
this and so with this I'm gonna pass it
over to Brett to talk about what
Pandora's gonna be doing for the rest of
2019 and what we kind of hope to see
them talk about it next next year thanks
Blake
[Applause]
so just just try to finish off real
quick so we have time for a couple
questions you know we we are part of the
way down a pretty long journey here but
some things we're already realizing is
the the separation of storage and
compute is one of the biggest things
biggest wins that we're getting out of
out of the move to a cloud enabling this
flexibility to scale out when you really
need to when you have a bottleneck it's
been really cool as an example we have
this job that the process is it's
essentially ETL on a lot of our listener
data it has probably the worst name
possible it's called the nightly job I
was it was the only job back in 2010
when we wrote it but but still does a
lot of the core processing of our
listener data that used to run or or
currently runs on Prem in just a little
over five hours we move that over to GCP
it's running running and data Prochnow
and it runs and I think an hour and a
half so that was a big bottleneck it's a
big dependency for this long chain of
jobs that we run every night and so
being able to scale that out reduce the
time puts us in a good position to
finish all the other nightly processing
and be ready for the next day
you know the operational overhead well
when we talk about lift and improve a
little bit so being able to to migrate
we didn't want to just lift and shift
take exactly what we were doing on Prem
and move it to a cloud so all these
things I mentioned about being being
able to scale out have really helped us
there the the ability to you know a hive
upgrade used to be a really big endeavor
for us it it took us about a year from
start to finish to test out the the
major high version to get all of our all
of our different teams that have tested
the job and do that upgrade and now with
data proc and
ephemeral clusters and having jobs being
able to use whatever version they need
to we can do this you know in a much
more staged fashion gives us a lot more
control and flexibility and the last
thing I would say is lean on google lean
on the PSO services they've been a great
partner for us you know a big migration
like this things do not always go right
features aren't always as advertised
that's that's just the fact people use
them in different ways
but Google has been a great partner when
we found an issue we reported it they
get back to us very quickly and we're
iterating on it so we really appreciate
that we know everything's not going to
be perfect but when you have a good
partner it makes a big difference also
access to features we got early access
to catalog or data catalog which has
been great a lot of big query features
that we get access to early so that was
really helpful so what's next for us
we're really focusing on optimization so
I'm going to finish the migration
beginning of next year along the way
we're doing a lot of optimization for
cost for speed and then really digging
in to see what we can leverage with all
the tools to improve the personalization
and listening experience for all of you
on Pandora
[Music]